- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Bonjour à tous.
La séance est ouverte.
Madame la Première
ministre, mesdames
et messieurs les membres
du gouvernement,
mesdames et messieurs les députés.
Dans la nuit du 18
au 19 novembre,
à Crépol dans la Drôme,
en pleine fête
de village, un drame est survenu.
Il choque notre pays tout entier.
Il plonge chacun
d'entre
nous dans une infinie tristesse.
Thomas, 16 ans,
a été poignardé à mort.
16 autres personnes
ont été blessées
à l'arme blanche,
dont 3 grièvement.
Un déchaînement de violence
a fait basculer
une commune française
dans l'horreur.
Je veux dire, au nom
de la représentation nationale,
toute notre solidarité
de coeur et d'esprit
devant cette tragédie.
Je veux saluer
la dignité et la gravité
de la marche
blanche qui a salué
la mémoire de Thomas.
Il importe que justice
soit rendue.
La justice n'est
ni la vengeance,
ni la vindicte.
Pour Thomas,
en signe de solidarité
avec ses parents,
sa famille, ses amis,
je vous demande,
mesdames et messieurs,
de bien vouloir
observer une minute
de silence.
Merci.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
comme je l'ai fait au Sénat
la semaine dernière,
je veux adresser
mes condoléances
et dire ma peine
aux parents, aux proches,
à tous les habitants
de Crépol
après la mort de Thomas.
Il avait 16 ans.
Il incarnait
le courage propre
à son sport, le rugby.
Il avait une vie
remplie d'espoir
et de promesses devant lui.
J'ai également une pensée
pour les personnes blessées,
dont certaines grièvement.
Je remercie
la maire de Crépol
pour son engagement.
Hier, le porte-parole
du gouvernement s'est rendu
sur place.
Il a pu échanger
avec la famille,
les habitants, les élus.
La mort de Thomas
est un drame
qui a touché et ému la France.
C'est une démonstration
de violence extrêmement choquante.
Toute la lumière
devrait être faite.
9 personnes ont déjà
été interpellées
et mises en examen.
J'ai toute confiance
en les enquêteurs
et les magistrats.
C'est grâce à eux que la justice
passera.
Certains individus violents
rendent impossible
le quotidien
de nos quartiers,
de nos villes et de nos villages.
C'est inacceptable.
Je veux le dire
aux parents de Thomas,
à tous les Français,
avec mon gouvernement,
nous serons intraitables.
J'ai annoncé
récemment un projet
de loi sur la justice
des mineurs
pour davantage
responsabiliser les parents,
et mieux sanctionner les jeunes.
Face à la désinhibition
de la violence
chez certains, il nous faut
de nouvelles réponses.
J'ai demandé aux ministres
Gérald Darmanin
et Eric Dupond-Moretti
de me faire
des propositions pour lutter
efficacement face
à ces bandes
et les empêcher de nuire.
Nous devons tout faire
pour qu'un tel drame
ne se reproduise pas.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
dans un tel moment,
nous avons un devoir d'unité,
de dignité,
sans minimiser les faits.
Un devoir de décence,
aussi, en respectant
le deuil de la famille
et des proches,
sans récupération
politique, sans attiser
les haines.
Applaudissements
Je condamne
avec la plus grande fermeté
les démonstrations
et les actes de violence
de l'ultradroite
ces derniers jours.
La justice ne vient
jamais de la violence.
Nous ne laisserons rien passer.
...
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
toute la lumière
doit être faite
sur la mort de Thomas
et nous y veillerons.
Vous pouvez compter sur moi
et mon gouvernement
pour lutter avec force
et détermination
contre les violences.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la Première ministre.
L'ordre du jour
appelle les questions
au gouvernement.
Je suis heureuse
de souhaiter la bienvenue
à deux délégations,
l'une
qui est la délégation de Moldavie,
et l'autre
du parlement fédérale
du Royaume de Belgique,
conduite
par le président de la section
bilatérale Belgique-France.
...
Merci.
La première question
va être posée
par monsieur
Henri Alfandari
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Henri Alfandari: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre
de l'Education nationale
et de la Jeunesse.
Les connaissances
des jeunes entrant
en 4e en 2023 ont fait l'objet
d'une évaluation nationale
sur 730.000 établissements.
Celle-ci montre
un effondrement
sans précédent de leur niveau.
Cela fait dire
à nos concitoyens
que la France est entrée
dans une dépression éducative
continue qui risque
de faire
de nous une nation d'illettrés.
Que va-t-il advenir
de notre démocratie
si tel est le cas?
A quelques jours
de la publication
des résultats
de la performance
des systèmes éducatifs,
nombreux s'inquiètent
de la place de la France.
Le système éducatif
a vu se développer
des ramifications
dans le programme scolaire.
Le développement
des enfants doit
être pensé de manière globale.
Si le français
et les maths
sont des savoirs
fondamentaux prioritaires,
nous ne pouvons
continuer à hiérarchiser
nos enseignants.
Si chaque élève
ne dispose pas des compétences
nécessaires, il est à craindre
que l'ensemble
des efforts
sur les temps scolaires
et périscolaires
ne soient voués à l'échec.
Le défi pour former
plus rapidement,
qualitativement
est peut-être voué l'échec.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Depuis 1987,
mon ministère, celui
de l'Education
nationale, fait passer
la même dictée
à un panel représentatif
des élèves de CM2.
En 1987, il y avait 10 fautes.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui
à 20 fautes
en moyenne.
En 1987, il n'y
avait que 6% des élèves
qui faisaient plus de 25 fautes.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui
à près de 30%.
En 1987,
il y avait près de 15%
des élèves qui faisaient
moins de 2 fautes.
Nous sommes à à peine
plus de 1% aujourd'hui.
Il y a une baisse du niveau.
Il faut la regarder sans fard.
Il faut y répondre.
Le point positif
des évaluations rendues
à la rentrée, c'est qu'on voit
qu'un investissement massif
qui permet d'inverser la tendance.
Le niveau des élèves
qui rentrent
en 6e cette année
s'améliore par rapport
au niveau des élèves
qui sont entrés
en 6e en 2017.
On voit que sur le français
et les mathématiques,
il y a une amélioration
du niveau
parce qu'on a réinvesti
massivement.
Il faut aller beaucoup plus loin.
J'ai ouvert un certain
nombre de chantiers.
J'aurai l'occasion
de faire des annonces
la semaine prochaine.
Laissez-passer
au collège un élève
qui ne sait ni lire,
ni écrire, ni compter,
cela relève forme de maltraitance.
Laisser entrer
au lycée un élève
qui accumule
un tel retard,
ce n'est pas possible.
Je vais annoncer
des mesures fortes
la semaine prochaine.
Je salue le travail
de l'Assemblée nationale
et des députés en charge.
Nous devons nous interroger
sur la place
du redoublement
et des groupes de niveaux
pour faire progresser
tout le monde.
Je vous donne rendez-vous
la semaine prochaine
pour annoncer
mon plan d'élévation
du niveau général.
Nous le devons
à nos élèves
et à notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Victor Catteau
pour le groupe
du Rassemblement National.
- Victor Catteau: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre.
Après l'injuste
et inutile réforme
des retraites,
vous avez décidé de continuer
à détrousser les Français.
Votre ministre
de l'Economie, monsieur
Bruno Le Maire,
a insulté les Français
en les exhortant
à se secouer les puces,
une phrase digne
du président
de la République
qu'il espère remplacer
en 2027.
Il a décidé de s'attaquer
à nos seniors,
les piliers de notre société,
en envisageant
de réduire la durée
des allocations chômage.
Votre gouvernement
écrase les Français
sous le poids de son mépris,
les réduisant
à une peine quotidienne.
L'âge
ne devrait pas être un fardeau.
Apprenez qu'être
au chômage à 55 ans
n'est pas un choix
de vie,
mais une contrainte
imposée
par les circonstances
dont vous êtes les responsables.
Les seniors
ne se complaisent pas
dans une retraite
forcée prématurée,
dans une France
où il faut choisir
entre manger et s'habiller.
Je vous laisserai expliquer
votre nouvelle lubie
aux Français.
Corentin, 58 ans,
recherche un emploi
depuis avril 2022.
Il fait
tout pour s'en sortir
et il s'inquiète
de l'avenir s'il
ne trouve pas d'emploi.
Votre devoir
est de prendre des mesures
pour résoudre
ces problèmes et non
de plonger ces personnes
dans un désespoir
plus profond.
Quand allez-vous
mettre fin
à cette oppression systématique?
Quand allez-vous
écouter et répondre
aux préoccupations
légitimes des Français?
Quand allez-vous
revenir à la réalité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Carole Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Chers collègues,
rappelons le contexte
dans lequel ces discussions
interviennent.
Le 10 novembre dernier,
les partenaires sociaux
ont conclu un accord
sur l'assurance-chômage,
qui s'inscrit
dans une réforme engagée
depuis 2019 et qui nous amène
à réfléchir
sur les conditions
d'indemnisation
du chômage et la modulation
de la durée d'indemnisation,
selon l'état
de la conjoncture du marché
du travail.
Cet accord
ne prévoit pas de dispositions
spécifiques
pour les situations liées
à la séniorité.
On voit bien au-delà
des principes dégagés
de cet accord, du montant
des économies visées,
qu'il y a des enjeux
à mettre en oeuvre
autour de la séniorité
sur l'assurance-chômage.
C'est ce qui est
à discuter
dans le cadre
des concertations sociales
sur les seniors,
et pour voir
dans cette période
complexe comment mettre
en place des modalités spécifiques
d'indemnisation chômage
des seniors,
il faut tenir compte
de la réforme
des retraites et du report
de l'âge d'ouverture des droits.
Cette question doit
être réouverte
avec les partenaires
sociaux
qui vont engager
cette négociation.
Il sera temps de voir
comment accompagner
les seniors
dans l'emploi,
et pour la fin de leur parcours
professionnel.
C'est un débat
qui viendra d'abord
par les partenaires
sociaux,
et que nous aurons ici
dans l'hémicycle
dans un second temps.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Victor Catteau:
Si en deux minutes,
il fallait résumer
l'incompétence,
l'impuissance
de votre gouvernement
à réagir aux problèmes
des Français,
vous venez de le démontrer.
Je voudrais rajouter:
vivement 2027!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Soumya Bourouaha
pour le groupe Gauche démocrate
et républicaine.
- Soumya Bourouaha: Merci.
Notre groupe s'associe
à l'hommage rendu
au jeune Thomas.
Suite aux violences imputées
à l'extrême droite
à Dublin, le Premier
ministre irlandais
a dénoncé les émeutiers
en déclarant
qu'elles faisaient honte
à Dublin, à l'Irlande.
Nous aurions aimé entendre
la même indignation
de la part
du gouvernement face
aux défilés
dans plusieurs villes
de mi-décembre d'extrême
droite, cherchant
à "casser des Noirs
et des Arabes".
Ces démonstrations
de force angoissent
nos concitoyens qui doutent
de la volonté politique
à défendre le vivre-ensemble.
Une partie
de la classe politique
ne condamne même
plus ces actes abjectes.
Pire, certains soufflent
sur les braises
en participant
au climat nauséabond
qui règne
dans notre pays
et qui est repris
en boucle
sur les chaînes
d'information en continu.
Cela fait maintenant
plusieurs années
que nous dénonçons
le tapis rouge
qui est déroulé
à l'extrême droite
et à son idéologie
raciste, xénophobe
et antisémite.
Les conséquences
de ces discours
de haine
sont en train de nous exploser
au visage et détruisent
les valeurs humanistes,
solidaires, qui constituent
les fondements
de notre République,
de plus en plus fracturée.
Il y a urgence à agir.
Il faut tout mettre
en oeuvre pour rétablir
le lien social,
répondre aux inquiétudes
des Français qui sont la crise
alimentaire,
la crise du logement,
l'environnement, l'insécurité...
Nous sommes face
à un tournant qui appelle
des politiques fortes
et courageuses,
éloignées
de celles que vous prônez.
Le projet de loi
de l'immigration
en est un de ces révélateurs.
Etes-vous déterminés
à mettre fin
à ce poison lent?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
chers collègues.
Vous avez raison.
Ce qu'il s'est passé
à Romans-sur-Isère
ou à Lyon est scandaleux.
En effet, cela mérite
une condamnation morale
et politique forte,
celle de milices d'extrême droite
qui sont venus
pour "taper des Noirs
et des Arabes"
pour mettre fin
à ce qu'ils pensent
être le "grand remplacement".
Je voudrais saluer le travail
du renseignement
qui a permis de documenter
et d'intervenir
sur ces actes.
Cela a permis de nombreuses
interpellations
qui ont pu entrer
en comparution immédiate.
Je salue la préfecture
et les policiers
de Lyon, où de nombreuses
interpellations
ont eu lieu suite
à une manifestation sauvage
avec des discours
fascistes et racistes.
Nous aussi,
nous voulons dire
que nous ne comprenons pas
pourquoi
il n'y a pas une condamnation
unanime
de ceux qui veulent
remplacer le droit
par la force,
ceux qui veulent faire
le travail des policiers
à leur place
en répétant qu'il y aurait
une race "supérieure"
à d'autres.
Je vous assure
que de nombreux moyens
sont mis en place pour suivre
les 1500 personnes radicalisées
de l'ultradroite,
pour pouvoir engager
des procédures
de dissolution,
comme je l'ai fait
avec Génération Identitaire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Benoît Bordat
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Benoît Bordat:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse
à Gérald Darmanin.
Dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche,
un homme de 55
ans a été tué
par des coups de feu
qui ciblaient
son domicile à Dijon.
Il est mort pendant son sommeil.
C'est une nouvelle
victime collatérale
d'un règlement de comptes
dans une affaire
de trafic de stupéfiants.
Je me suis rendu
sur place pour constater
les faits et recueillir
les sentiments
des habitants.
Ils sont choqués, désemparés.
La drogue est un cancer
qui ronge
notre pays, tue
des innocents et détruit
la santé des consommateurs.
Cela engraisse les trafiquants
qui font régner
leur loi dans les quartiers,
les rues,
les cages d'escalier.
Elle pourrit la vie
à des milliers
de Français.
La drogue finance
des réseaux criminels,
la prostitution,
les ventes d'armes...
Je connais
votre engagement
et celui du gouvernement
dans la lutte
contre le trafic de drogue
et les bons résultats
que les forces
de l'ordre ont présenté
en mars dernier.
Malgré les moyens
importants alloués
à la justice,
l'augmentation des effectifs
des forces de l'ordre
notamment à Dijon,
le sentiment d'insécurité
et l'insécurité persistent.
Pas de liberté véritable
sans la sécurité.
Le fléau de la drogue
doit être enrayé
au plus vite.
Comment peut-on
davantage associer
les collectivités,
les bailleurs
et les élus locaux
dans cette lutte prioritaire?
Comment redonner
de l'espoir aux habitants
qui aspirent
légitimement à vivre
en paix?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
je voudrais
avoir une pensée
pour cette famille
qui a perdu un homme
de 55 ans qui,
dans son sommeil,
a connu la mort
par ceux qui utilisent
des armes
pour faire "la marchandise
de la mort",
comme vous l'avez très bien dit.
Ce point de deal à Dijon
est très surveillé.
Les règlements
de comptes sont parfois
la conséquence
du travail de la justice
et de la police.
Des moyens importants
sont mis en place.
Le préfet de Dijon
a eu l'occasion
de le redire.
Vous avez l'occasion
de le constater.
Nous portons
des coups très durs
contre la drogue,
et une bataille
de territoires peut
parfois naître.
J'ai décidé d'octroyer
des moyens supplémentaires
à Dijon et de lutter
à Villeurbanne,
à Nîmes.
Il y a trois mois,
des faits divers similaires
ont eu lieu.
30 interpellations
à Nîmes, deux mois
plus tard.
Une vingtaine
à Vaulx-en-Velin, également.
Nous avons démantelé
des points de deal.
Cela mènera à des condamnations
exemplaire,
je l'espère.
Il faut une volonté
pour lutter
contre la drogue.
Il faut la fin
de la consommation
par les personnes.
S'il n'y
avait pas de consommateurs,
il n'y aurait pas de dealers.
Il faut tenir contre la drogue
le même discours,
celui que les consommateurs
font naître
les trafics.
Nous devons
être intraitables
contre ces consommateurs,
en même temps
que contre ces dealers
qui financent
le terrorisme,
le proxénétisme,
et les discours
que nous entendons
qui condamnent
les morts de règlements
de comptes
tout en menant un débat
sur la légalisation
du cannabis
et de la cocaïne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Bertrand Pancher
pour le groupe LIOT.
- Bertrand Pancher:
Nous entamons l'examen
de la loi de contrôle
de l'immigration
et du renforcement
de l'intégration.
Je veux dire ici
que lorsque l'on parle
de migrants, il s'agit
d'êtres humains.
Un migrant, c'est un homme.
Un migrant, c'est une femme.
Un migrant, c'est un enfant.
Etre français,
c'est connaître
notre histoire.
Notre pays s'est construit
par vagues d'immigration
successives.
Mon grand-père
était italien d'origine.
Cette particularité,
je la partage
avec Eric Ciotti
et Jordan Bardella, notamment.
Je connais cette histoire,
le mépris,
les rejets et la bêtise humaine.
Un rapport du préfet du nord
au siècle dernier expliquait
que les Italiens vivaient
toujours ensemble,
ne parlaient pas le français,
sentaient mauvais
et qu'ils étaient inassimilables.
Mon grand-père
a combattu à Verdun
et deux de ses frères
sont morts
pour la France.
Etre français,
c'est défendre les valeurs
de la République.
C'est faire vivre
la devise "Liberté,
égalité, fraternité".
Cette immigration
doit nous permettre
d'être plus efficaces
et plus justes.
Nous sommes pour le réalisme.
La question de l'aide
médicale d'Etat
qui permet aux étrangers
en situation irrégulière
de se soigner sous certaines
conditions doit
être étudiée par ce prisme.
Les sénateurs ont voté
sa suppression.
En 2012, l'Espagne
avait pris la même
décision avant de revenir
dessus,
car cela avait entraîné
une hausse
des coûts et 15%
de la mortalité
des personnes concernées.
Ce serait un grand
risque à prendre
pour la santé de tous
nos compatriotes.
Quelle est la position
précise
de votre gouvernement
sur cette question?
Elle est importante.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Chers collègues,
monsieur Bertrand Pancher.
L'examen du projet de loi
immigration porté
par le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin
a commencé hier en commission.
Ce projet de loi répond
à une préoccupation
de nos concitoyens.
Il vise à relever
un double défi:
éloigner
plus efficacement
ceux qui n'ont pas le droit
de rester
en France
et mieux intégrer
ceux que nous choisissons
d'accueillir.
Je suis certaine
que nous pouvons
nous retrouver
autour de ces objectifs
avec les parlementaires
de votre groupe,
comme avec ceux
d'autres groupes
de l'arc républicain.
Lors de l'examen
du texte au Sénat,
l'AME a été supprimé au profit
d'une aide médicale d'urgence.
La position
de mon gouvernement
est claire,
c'est un dispositif nécessaire.
Cela répond à un impératif
de santé publique
et permet de soigner
les maladies présentes
sur notre sol sans passer
nécessairement
par les services d'urgence.
Cela permet de prendre
en charge rapidement
des maladies et d'éviter
leur propagation,
comme le VIH,
ou encore les infections
respiratoires.
C'est un dispositif
extrêmement contrôlé.
Monsieur le président
Pancher, une réforme
de l'AME a déjà été menée en 2019.
Elle s'était
faite logiquement
dans le cadre de la loi
de financement
de la Sécurité sociale.
Avec mon gouvernement,
je cherche
comme vous l'efficacité
de nos politiques publiques.
Je suis ouverte
à des évolutions
de l'AME.
Nous avons besoin
d'un diagnostic complet
et objectif.
C'est l'objet
de la mission confiée
par les ministres
Gérald Darmanin,
Aurélien Rousseau
et Agnès Firmin
Le Bodo.
Les conclusions de cette mission
seront rendues d'ici
quelques jours.
Avec les ministres,
nous proposons
les évolutions
nécessaires dans le cadre
d'un texte adapté.
Nous sommes déterminés
à apporter
des réponses justes
et efficaces
aux Français.
Cela vaut sur l'AME
comme sur les autres sujets.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Pierre Taite
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Jean-Pierre Taite:
Madame la présidente,
ma question s'adresse à madame
la secrétaire d'Etat
à l'enfance.
Vous avez annoncé
le maintien
de la Ciivise
avec des missions élargies.
Les chiffres qui suivent
sont insupportables.
Toutes les 3 minutes,
un enfant
est victime d'inceste de violence.
165.000 enfants sont victimes
d'agressions sexuelles.
A l'échelle d'une classe,
cela représente 1 enfant
sur 5.
80% des agressions
sont intrafamiliales
et 50% des victimes
disent
ne pas avoir été
soutenues
par leurs propres parents.
Ces chiffres donnent
envie de vomir.
La Première ministre
a lancé un plan
contre les violences
sexuelles
contre les enfants.
Une association
de ma circonscription
fait un travail
remarquable pour repérer
des enfants victimes
d'agissements monstrueux.
Cette association
a reçu une subvention
que vous avez supprimée
en 2023, plongeant
les bénévoles
dans un profond désarroi.
L'association peut-elle
de nouveau toucher
cette subvention
pour continuer à sauver
des enfants
victimes d'inceste
et de violences?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Charlotte Caubel.
- Charlotte Caubel: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Jean-Pierre Taite,
je vous remercie
pour votre question.
Madame la Première
ministre a présenté
un plan de lutte
contre les violences sexuelles
à l'occasion du comité du Ciivise.
Ce plan ambitieux
est accompagné
de renforts de moyens
humains et financiers
pour tous les acteurs
de la lutte
contre cette violence.
1 enfant sur 10,
c'est inacceptable,
y compris
dans les suites données
à ces enfants.
Un renfort financier
de ces moyens,
une campagne
de sensibilisation,
une plate-forme,
la réécriture des programmes,
le maillage
de l'éducation,
bref, un plan
à la hauteur des enjeux.
Nous souhaitons
que le travail
de la Ciivise continue
avec des modalités renouvelées
et centrées
sur certaines missions
sur les violences sexuelles.
Nous présenterons les détails
avec Eric Dupond-Moretti
dans les prochaines semaines.
La lutte contre les violences
sexuelles,
c'est l'affaire
de tous et de toutes,
y compris du secteur
associatif
dont nous avons besoin.
Vous appelez mon attention
sur une association
qui fait un travail
remarquable
dans votre territoire.
Elle a été financée
dans le cadre
d'un appel à projets en 2022.
Le nouveau plan
Violences comprend
de nouveaux financements
pour des appels
à projets ambitieux.
Nous regarderons ensemble
si l'association peut
de nouveau
recouvrer
des sommes pour conduire
ces projets.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
- Jean-Pierre Taite:
Je connais
les blessures
vécues en silence
par un enfant.
Loin du regard
des autres,
comme on dit.
Je vis au quotidien
avec un enfant
de 14 ans qui a vécu
avec des violences physiques
et psychologiques
de la part
de son père.
Brigitte Macron
a dit: "Mon but
est de porter
la voix de ceux
qu'on entend pas."
Elle a raison.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Caroline Yadan
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Caroline Yadan: Merci.
Cette question s'adresse à madame
Bérangère Couillard.
52 jours déjà
se sont écoulés
depuis ce samedi sanglant,
au cours duquel
un gouffre abyssal
s'est ouvert,
où notre humanité a été aspirée.
Un gouffre de sens et de larmes.
Une violence absolue commise
au nom d'Allahu akbar
par des monstres
armés de couteaux
et dépourvus de coeur.
Le 7 octobre dernier,
les terroristes
du Hamas ont pénétré le territoire
souverain d'Israël
pour commettre de telles atrocités
qu'un esprit humain aurait
du mal à concevoir.
Les associations
féministes adeptent
des MeToo, d'écriture inclusive,
auraient dû condamner
avec force les viols acharnés,
les femmes enceintes éventrées,
la nudité carbonisée,
les adolescentes exhibées
comme autant de macabres trophées.
Il n'en a pourtant rien été.
Les nouvelles féministes
intersectionnelles
se sont tues.
Elles ont balayé
d'un revers de main
les victimes
de ces abominations,
sous le prétexte
de leur origine israélienne
et juive.
Elles ont effacé la douleur
de ces femmes suppliciées,
parfois même
en idolâtrant la violence
de leurs bourreaux,
devenus soudainement
des résistants.
Ce féminisme
à géométrie variable
a choisi d'exclure
samedi dernier l'accès
à la marche
contre les violences faites
aux femmes, aux manifestantes
venues rappeler
la mémoire des femmes
victimes du pogrom
du 7 octobre, parfois
encore retenues
comme otages.
Que comptez-vous
faire pour garantir
que les subventions de l'Etat
ne puissent profiter
à ces associations qui...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Bérangère Couillard.
Applaudissements
- Bérangère Couillard:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés, madame
la députée Caroline Yadan.
Ce qu'il s'est passé
en Israël est abominable.
Des femmes ont été violées,
mutilées, torturées.
Le viol est une arme de guerre.
Il laisse de nombreuses femmes
psychologiquement traumatisées.
La violence
sexuelle n'est
souvent pas perpétrée
par des soldats solitaires.
Elle s'apparente à une tactique
de guerre délibérée.
La violence sexuelle déplace,
terrorise, détruit
des individus, des familles
et des communautés entières,
atteignant des niveaux
de cruauté inimaginables.
Ces horreurs,
qu'elles aient eu lieu
en Israël,
où de nombreux cas de viol
ont été rapportés,
en Ukraine,
au Soudan ou dans le reste
du monde,
je les condamne fermement.
Vous évoquez particulièrement
la manifestation
du 25 novembre.
Pourquoi a-t-elle été créée?
Pour lutter
contre les violences faites
aux femmes.
C'est un combat universel,
et je dénonce
de nouveau ici
l'instrumentalisation
qui en a été faite.
On ne trie pas les violences
en fonction
des conflits,
des individus,
des nations ou des nationalités.
Je m'oppose à toute forme
de récupération.
C'est là que la diplomatie
féministe
a toute son importance.
Tous les conflits
rappellent la nécessité
de la mise en oeuvre
de l'agenda Femmes,
paix, sécurité.
Cela
est indispensable
pour avoir un impact
positif
sur la paix.
104 Etats-membres
des Nations Unies
ont déjà adopté ce plan d'action.
Au niveau national,
vous me posez
la question des subventions
aux associations.
Sachez que les projets
soumis
à ces subventions doivent
s'inscrire pleinement
dans les orientations
de mon ministère
et je suis très vigilante
à ce que les associations
partagent nos valeurs
universelles.
Elles ne seront
soutenues
que si elles partagent
ces valeurs universelles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Emeric Salmon
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Emeric Salmon:
Madame la présidente,
chers collègues.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre délégué en charge
du Renouveau démocratique.
Le 29 mai 2005,
le peuple français
a dit non à la ratification
du traité établissant
une Constitution pour l'Europe.
Les Français
ont donc dit non
à cette construction
à marche forcée
vers le fédéralisme,
et ont rappelé
qu'ils voulaient
avoir leur mot à dire
sur la Construction européenne.
Nous savons tous
que contre l'avis
des Français,
le traité de Lisbonne,
pâle copie
de la Constitution,
a été imposé par Nicolas Sarkozy.
La semaine dernière,
suite à une proposition
du groupe macroniste,
deux résolutions tendant
à la révision
de la Constitution
ont été adoptées.
C'est une étape
de plus vers le fédéralisme.
Je n'ai pas le temps
de revenir
sur l'ensemble des mesures
antidémocratiques contenues
dans ces textes,
et je n'en présenterai qu'une
seule.
Le choix d'augmenter
le nombre de domaines
dans lesquels les actions
sont décidées
par un vote
à la majorité qualifiée,
en lieu et place
de l'unanimité,
garante de la souveraineté
des nations.
Marine Le Pen a proposé
une déclaration
des droits
des peuples
et des nations
qui réaffirme notamment
la supériorité
du droit national
sur toute institution
supranationale.
Ma question sera simple.
Laisserez-vous le Parlement
européen imposer
aux Français
cette accélération
vers le fédéralisme,
où allez-vous donner
du sens à votre ministère
du Renouveau démocratique
en interrogeant
les Français
sur ce sujet, notamment
par un référendum?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Becht.
- Olivier Becht: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
excusez la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères,
qui est retenue
en réunion ministérielle
de l'OTAN.
Les institutions
ont évolué en Europe
depuis 1950, depuis 73 ans.
Nous avons eu
le premier traité,
le traité de Paris,
puis celui de Rome,
de Luxembourg,
de Maastricht,
ou encore de Lisbonne.
A chaque fois, l'Union Européenne
s'est transformée
pour faire face
à des défis
qui étaient parfois liés
à son établissement,
parfois à son approfondissement.
La semaine dernière,
le Parlement européen
a proposé une révision
des traités.
Cette révision sera transmise
au Conseil européen
qui décidera des suites à donner.
Le Parlement européen
est dans son rôle
en proposant une rectification
des traités.
Il appartiendra
aux Etats de décider.
Vous savez que cela se fait
à l'unanimité
des Etats.
Ensuite, il y aura un processus
démocratique propre
à chaque Etat pour modifier
ces traités face
au contexte
que nous connaissons,
notamment celui
du retour de la guerre
en Europe, d'un certain
nombre de crises
à la frontière
de l'Union Européenne,
et dont il convient
de se protéger.
La vraie
différence,
c'est que votre camp,
depuis des années,
veut déconstruire
l'Europe, déconstruire
une Europe qui nous protège,
qui protège l'Union Européenne
de la guerre,
qui nous permet de vivre
la période de paix
la plus longue
que nous n'avons
jamais connue
depuis 2001.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Emeric Salmon:
Vous n'avez pas compris
les Français.
Vous ne voulez pas donner
la parole
aux Français.
Ils ont une date
à retenir: le 9 juin,
en votant Jordan Bardella.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Arnaud Le Gall
pour le groupe
La France Insoumise.
- Arnaud Le Gall:
Ma question s'adresse
à la ministre
des Affaires étrangères.
Il y a quelques jours,
18 anciens ambassadeurs
de France ont appelé
à un rééquilibrage
de notre diplomatie
au Moyen-Orient.
Le Hamas a fait
13.000 morts civils
à Gaza.
Ils s'inquiètent d'une politique
d'une terreur opérée
par les colons
en Cisjordanie
avec le soutien
du gouvernement israélien.
La trêve en cours
à Gaza a permis
la libération d'otages.
Nous partageons
votre immense soulagement
après la libération
de trois otages mineurs
franco-israéliens.
C'est insuffisant au regard
de la souffrance
des familles.
Cela a permis la livraison
d'aide humanitaire,
mais c'est insuffisant.
Le 9 novembre,
Emmanuel Macron a appelé
à un cessez-le-feu.
La ministre
des Affaires étrangères
a dit: "La France
considère qu'il faut
une trêve qui permet
d'aboutir
à un cessez-le-feu."
Pour que ces paroles
soient entendues,
il faut des actes.
Que fait la France, concrètement?
Cette étape est décisive.
Elle doit
être la première
vers une solution politique,
en particulier
une solution à deux Etats qui n'a
jamais été tentée.
Il faut que la diplomatie
française
soit au rendez-vous
de son histoire
et de la paix.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Becht.
- Olivier Becht: Merci.
Permettez-moi à nouveau
d'excuser l'absence
de la ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères retenue
en réunion ministérielle
de l'OTAN.
Je me réjouis
comme vous du retour
de ces trois enfants.
Néanmoins, notre joie
est contenue,
puisque nous pensons
toujours aux 5 Français
qui sont toujours
portés disparus
et qui sont encore probablement
otages
du Hamas.
Nous ne ménageons
aucun effort
pour les rendre
à l'affection
de leurs familles.
La France n'abandonne
aucun de ses concitoyens.
La position de la France
est constante.
Elle n'a pas évolué
depuis quasiment
les débuts de la Ve République.
Nous avons toujours
été favorables
à une solution
à deux Etats, la seule
qui permette
à deux peuples de vivre
en paix et en sécurité,
côte à côte.
Nous ne ménageons pas
les efforts
de la diplomatie
française pour faire
en sorte que la trêve
humanitaire
que nous appelons
depuis des semaines,
et qui a permis
la libération des otages,
puisse être prolongée,
et qu'elle puisse déboucher
sur un cessez-le-feu
qui permettrait
de réengager le processus
politique, afin
que deux Etats puissent
vivre en sécurité.
C'est tout le sens
de l'engagement
de la diplomatie française.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
- Arnaud Le Gall:
Je crains
que cette voie
ne soit pas assez entendue.
J'appelle à marcher
pour la paix,
la justice et à un cessez-le-feu
permanent.
Ce sera samedi à 14h.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Je passe la parole
à monsieur Bruno Millienne
pour le groupe démocrate.
- Bruno Millienne:
Ma question s'adresse
à la ministre chargée
des Personnes handicapées.
Pour commencer,
je voudrais associer
notre groupe à la douleur
de la famille
et des proches
du jeune Thomas,
que nous partageons.
Depuis six ans,
nous agissons pour soutenir
les professionnels
du secteur du handicap.
Nous voulons les amener
vers des parcours professionnels.
Le projet de loi plein
emploi permettra
aux travailleurs
handicapés de bénéficier
de l'essentiel
des droits individuels.
Nous offrons aux personnes
en situation
de handicap la possibilité
de s'auto-déterminer
et nous facilitons
leur recherche d'emploi
en milieu ordinaire.
J'ai été alerté du fait
que mon département
des Yvelines
est l'un de ceux
les moins bien dotés
en foyers de vie
ou médicalisés
pour personnes en situation
de handicap.
Leur inquiétude
est grande sur l'avenir
des établissements.
Je sais que vous n'en doutez
absolument pas.
Cependant,
en faisant converger
les droits
des travailleurs
vers ceux des salariés,
le gouvernement
fait peser
sur ces établissements
le financement
de ces dispositifs
qu'ils ont du mal à supporter.
Dans les Yvelines,
pour les 16 établissements,
c'est un déficit de près
de 400.000 euros annuels.
Un risque de fermeture
n'est pas exclu.
Cela rendrait les personnes
qui travaillent
sans accompagnement
et sans emploi.
Quelle solution le gouvernement
compte-t-il mettre
en place pour répondre
à ces inquiétudes
et garantir
dans les Yvelines
comme ailleurs la pérennité
de l'accompagnement
par le travail
des Français en situation
de handicap?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Fadila Khattabi,
ministre en charge
des Personnes handicapées.
- Fadila Khattabi: Merci.
Vous mettez le doigt
sur un vrai sujet:
la transformation
du modèle des ESAT.
Nous avons mis fin à une véritable
injustice sociale
en alignant les droits
des travailleurs
sur ceux des salariés.
Grâce au projet
de loi plein-emploi
ces travailleurs
pourront bénéficier
de la prime transport,
d'une complémentaire santé
et d'une prime exceptionnelle.
Ce n'était pas le cas
jusqu'à présent.
Cela a un impact financier
sur ces établissements.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle,
avec Olivier Dussopt,
nous avons lancé
une mission qui nous permettra
de refonder
le système de financement
tout en continuant
de garantir la qualité
de l'accompagnement
des personnes
en situation de handicap
au sein de ces établissements.
J'en profite
pour saluer la qualité
du travail qui est mené
par l'ensemble
des professionnels du secteur.
Nous avons pu
encore le constater hier,
avec Marc Fesneau,
dans le Loir-et-Cher,
où nous étions en déplacement.
Notre gouvernement agit.
20 millions d'euros
ont été versés
dans un premier temps,
pour aller
vers la transformation des ESAT.
Ces établissements
doivent se transformer
pour faciliter
les parcours
vers le milieu ordinaire.
Nous attendons
les conclusions
de la mission
pour pouvoir garantir
leur soutenabilité
financière
sur la durée.
Nous avons amélioré
la situation sociale
des personnes
en situation de handicap
qui travaillent
en ESAT,
nous sommes en train
de travailler
sur leur situation
financière pour faire
en sorte que le modèle
puisse être pérennisé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Guillaume Garot.
- Guillaume Garot:
Monsieur le ministre
de la Santé, l'association
UFC-Que Choisir
a déposé un recours
pour inaction
de l'Etat face
à la désertification médicale,
qui ne cesse d'avancer.
6 millions de Français
sont sans médecin traitant,
9 millions
de Français vivent
dans un désert médical.
C'est votre médecin
qui part en retraite
et qui n'est pas
remplacé,
ce sont des mois
et des mois
pour avoir un rendez-vous
chez un spécialiste,
et ce sont des listes
entières de dentistes
qui ne prennent plus de patients.
C'est ça, la réalité.
Depuis des années,
l'Etat a enchaîné
des mesures d'incitation
pour nos médecins,
avec des chèques
pour s'installer là
où on a besoin d'eux.
Peine perdue.
Ca n'a rien réglé,
ça coûte un "pognon
de dingue",
comme dirait le président
de la République.
Les inégalités de soins
se sont aggravées.
Le temps est venu
de réguler l'installation
et l'exercice
médical,
comme cela se fait
pour les pharmaciens,
pour kinés,
pour les infirmières,
pour mieux répartir
nos forces médicales
à l'échelle
du territoire national.
Je vous le dis,
notre santé
ne peut pas dépendre
de notre code postal.
Monsieur le ministre
de la Santé,
la majorité,
le gouvernement se refuse
à cette régulation.
Ce recours d'UFC-Que Choisir
est l'expression
de l'incompréhension
des Français
devant l'incapacité
du gouvernement
à résister au corporatisme.
Notre groupe de travail
transpartisan
a fait des propositions
très précises
sur les déserts
médicaux pour sortir
des politiques
qui ne marchent pas.
Quand allez-vous accepter
enfin d'y travailler?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau,
ministre de la Santé
et de la Prévention.
- Aurélien Rousseau:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur Guillaume Garot,
quand le président
de la République
décide dès 2018
de lever
le numerus clausus
et que nous formons
10.000 médecins
alors que nous en formions
dans les années 90, de l'inaction?
Pour permettre de recruter
et de fidéliser
dans les hôpitaux,
la Première ministre
a annoncé
l'augmentation de 25%
des personnels
à l'hôpital pour la nuit,
de l'inaction?
Deux maisons de santé
pluriprofessionnelles installées
sur le territoire, de l'inaction?
Inaction
encore quand les négociations
conventionnelles
pour l'attractivité
et l'installation
des professionnels
de santé ont été posées
par le gouvernement?
Inaction quand le projet
de loi de financement
de la Sécurité
sociale,
que vous avez souhaité
et sur lequel
vous avez souhaité
censurer le gouvernement
la semaine dernière,
permet d'étendre
les compétences à d'autres
professionnels médicaux
pour prendre
en charge la santé
de nos concitoyens?
Il n'y a pas d'inaction,
monsieur
le député.
Peut-être y a-t-il un débat
sur la coercition.
C'est celle que vous prônez.
Elle a été discutée
à de nombreuses reprises
dans cet hémicycle.
Je pense
qu'il ne faut pas confondre
l'inaction,
la détermination
qui est celle
de ce gouvernement
et de cette majorité,
et la prestidigitation,
qui est plutôt votre orientation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Marie Pochon,
pour le groupe écologiste.
- Marie Pochon: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre.
Deux France
irréconciliables,
un risque de basculement,
une guerre civile évitée,
la violence, la colère
qui font monter
la haine.
Voilà la situation
de notre pays
depuis le dramatique
décès de Thomas
dans le petit village de Crépol.
J'ai grandi juste à côté.
Thomas avait 16 ans.
Jamais il n'aurait dû mourir.
Une fête de village,
16 blessés
et un mort.
Pour le village
de Crépol, plus rien
ne sera comme avant.
C'est un miroir
de la société
où on plante pour une moquerie.
De quoi parle-t-on?
Depuis une semaine,
les ratonnades d'extrême droite
terrorisent
toute personne
qui n'aurait pas la bonne
couleur
de peau, la bonne religion.
La haine se répand.
On donne des noms en pâture.
On parle d'islamophobie
et de racisme.
Cette haine qui se répand
est l'aboutissement
de tant d'échecs.
La promesse
républicaine n'a
plus de valeur.
Votre discours cache
la fracture territoriale.
L'ordre, l'ordre,
l'ordre, cela peine
à masquer
la jeunesse mise
au pas du SNU, les bras tendus
à l'extrême droite
et les manifestations pour rien.
Les promesses
n'engagent
que ceux qui y croient.
La promesse
républicaine
n'est pas une petite promesse.
C'est la garantie
de notre vivre ensemble,
le fondement
de ce que nous sommes.
A Crépol, on a souvent
l'impression
qu'elle n'est pas faite pour nous.
Elle devrait être votre seul cap.
Vous avez failli.
Quand allez-vous prendre
vos responsabilités?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Véran, ministre
en charge du Renouveau
démocratique
et porte-parole du gouvernement.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Madame la députée
Marie Pochon, en écoutant
votre question,
j'ai peur que vous soyez
en train de passer
à côté
de quelque chose
qui se passe
dans notre pays.
J'ai peur
que vous n'ayez pas été
à l'écoute
de ce que nous avons entendu
hier, lorsque
nous étions dans la Drôme.
Vous n'étiez pas
avec moi
quand j'ai rencontré
la famille de Thomas.
Vous étiez avec moi
dans ce lycée
au sein duquel
vous avez eu deux peurs
qui se sont exprimées:
la peur
de la jeunesse
de Crépol de voir
les amis des assaillants
de Thomas entraîner
des représailles
à leur encontre,
et la peur des habitants
du quartier
de la Monnaie.
Ils ont le seul
tort d'habiter
dans le même quartier
et ils ont peur
de subir à leur tour
des représailles
de la part d'une
partie des habitants.
Quand on parle de risque
de basculement
de la société,
nous luttons
contre le fait
qu'il y ait deux France
qui ne puissent plus communiquer.
Je laisse cela aux extrêmes.
Vous ne pouvez pas faire
le lien
dans la question
que vous posez,
vu la douleur
des familles et la peur
que nous avons ressentie
dans la Drôme,
vous ne pouvez pas faire
le lien
avec des choses
telles que le 49.3
ou le SNU.
Ce que la population
nous demande
est de montrer
que l'Etat est ferme
et que l'autorité
républicaine est là.
9 personnes ont été
interpellées
en moins de trois jours.
Les chefs
d'accusation retenus
par le procureur
sont passibles,
pour l'auteur
de l'assassinat présumé,
de la peine de prison
à perpétuité.
La Première
ministre en a parlé
tout à l'heure,
nous luttons
contre ces bandes
armées qui sèment
la pagaille.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la députée?
- Marie Pochon:
La promesse républicaine,
ce n'est pas que l'ordre
et l'ordre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Emmanuel Lacresse
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Emmanuel Lacresse:
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Industrie, ma question
sur la réindustrialisation
de notre pays
est la mienne
et celle d'un collègue
de Chartres.
Une étude montre le succès
de la politique d'attractivité.
C'est le produit
de la mobilisation
des acteurs locaux
ainsi que la simplification
administrative
et la fourniture d'une énergie
décarbonée bon marché.
C'est notre énergie
nucléaire
dont le régulateur a dit
qu'elle pourrait
être fournie
à des prix contenus
par l'énergéticien national.
Vous lancez la semaine
de l'industrie
qui valorisera les lycées
professionnels.
Le ministre des Finances
se trouvait
il y a quelques jours
en Nouvelle-Calédonie
pour poursuivre
la production de nickel.
Vous avez signé
les 50 conventions
qui détaillent
la quantité des sites
les plus émetteurs de CO2.
Quel sera le rythme,
en particulier
pour le passage à la biomasse
des sites charbonniers?
Je pense à la transformation
du sel, notamment.
Le deuxième axe est celui
de l'hydrogène.
Pour décarboner la chimie
et la sidérurgie
dans la vallée
de la Moselle, il faudra
des ressources
considérables pour produire
de l'hydrogène vert
et le transporter.
Dans cette mesure,
nous attendons
un effort décisif
pour la recherche,
y compris pour les universités.
Notre industrie
lourde
est devant une étape décisive.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Roland Lescure,
en charge de l'Industrie.
- Roland Lescure:
Monsieur le député
Emmanuel Lacresse,
merci
pour votre question.
Nous étions à Chartres
la semaine dernière
avec le président
de la République
pour annoncer un investissement
exceptionnel.
Un grand groupe
pharmaceutique danois choisit
à nouveau la France
pour investir
un montant exceptionnel.
Ces bonnes
nouvelles
n'arrivent pas par hasard.
Elles sont aussi
le résultat
de six ans
de travail acharné
de ce gouvernement
et de ses prédécesseurs
pour rendre la France attractive.
La réindustrialisation doit
se faire partout
et chez vous,
en Meurthe-et-Moselle.
En Nouvelle-Calédonie aussi,
où le développement
de la voiture électrique donne
de nouvelles perspectives
au nickel.
Ce défi fait face
à deux écueils majeurs.
Le premier: nous aurons besoin
de ressources énergétiques.
La biomasse, l'hydrogène,
l'électricité décarbonée.
Avec la ministre
de la Transition énergétique,
nous vous présenterons un plan
sur l'hydrogène,
qui vous est cher,
et qui est cher
à votre territoire.
Deuxième défi majeur:
celui des talents.
Il y a 2000 travailleurs
pour construire
un chantier dans une usine
déjà occupée
par 6000 personnes.
J'engage tous
les parlementaires
de tous les bancs
à s'engager
dans la semaine
de l'industrie,
qui met en place 5500
événements partout
en France
qui vont donner envie
à nos jeunes hommes
et à nos jeunes femmes
de rejoindre l'industrie.
La réindustrialisation
doit nous rassembler
et elle doit concerner
tout le monde.
Cela doit mener
nos jeunes à l'industrie
et à gagner ce combat
de toute une génération.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Rachel Keke
pour le groupe
La France Insoumise.
- Rachel Keke: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur,
il s'appelait Thomas,
il avait 16 ans,
il a été tué le lundi 19 novembre.
Je voudrais ici
lui rendre hommage,
saluer sa mémoire,
dire ma solidarité
à ses proches,
sa famille
et tous les blessés.
L'extrême droite
a instrumentalisé
son meurtre.
Des expéditions vengeresses
ont été lancées.
A Romans-sur-Isère,
à Lyon, à Grenoble
et à Rennes, un seuil
a été franchi.
Qu'avez-vous fait
pour protéger
nos concitoyens
de ces bandes néonazies
qui agressent, qui terrorisent?
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur,
l'heure est grave.
Quels mots poser,
quels faits utiliser
pour vous faire réagir?
Faut-il vous rappeler
les croix gammées taguées
sur les murs de nos villes,
la profanation
des tombes juives
et musulmanes,
les ratonnades
et les meurtres racistes?
Monsieur le ministre,
nous vous alertons
depuis des mois
sur ces milices privées.
Que font les services
de renseignement?
Comment les agresseurs
de Romans-sur-Isère ont-ils eu
accès à la liste des suspects?
Les décisions judiciaires
ne suffisent pas.
Arrêtez de semer la confusion.
L'extrême droite
est antisémite,
islamophobe et raciste.
Les choses sont claires,
pour nous.
Pour eux, la République
doit être fracturée.
Pour nous, elle doit rester unie.
Je vais finir
par un message très fort,
surtout pour les jeunes:
nos origines
sont une richesse.
Tenons notre ligne!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin,
ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée,
je pense avoir répondu
à votre collègue
du groupe communiste
pour dire qu'il faut condamner
ces milices d'extrême droite,
d'ultradroite,
qui veulent, à la place
de l'Etat
et des policiers,
lutter
contre ce qu'ils pensent
être le grand remplacement.
Vous avez raison,
et c'est pour cela
que je voudrais,
plutôt que de les remettre
cause, remercier
les services
de renseignement
qui ont déjoué 13 attentats
de l'ultradroite
et d'extrême droite en France.
Je voudrais les remercier
d'avoir permis,
à Romans-sur-Isère,
d'avoir évité
un scénario tragique,
en mettant
en place des policiers
qui ont pu interpeller
une dizaine de personnes
qui ont été présentées
au service du garde
des Sceaux et condamnées
à des peines
extrêmement fermes
qui ont été critiquées
mais qui font l'honneur
de la République.
Nous promettons
les dissolutions,
comme on l'a fait
avec Génération Identitaire.
Je regrette
que vous ne nous ayez
pas accompagné sur cette décision.
Vous avez lutté
contre la loi séparatisme
qui permet ces dissolutions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Michèle Martinez
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Michèle Martinez:
Madame la présidente,
ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Justice.
La barbarie se déchaîne
dans notre pays
et la liste
des victimes s'allonge.
Cet ensauvagement
n'épargne
plus aucun endroit en France.
Que l'on soit chez soi
ou au supermarché,
la campagne ou à la ville,
partout s'installe
une terreur quotidienne.
Vous restez plutôt
prompt à dénoncer
la légitimation de l'opposition.
Nos vies sont plus que jamais
en sursis,
en témoignent les assassinats
de Thomas, Lola
et Enzo, la mort
d'un homme de 55 ans
ainsi que la mort
d'un couple de retraités
à Ambroise.
Rien d'étonnant
quand on sait que l'un
des agresseurs
présumés de Thomas
a été condamné
à une amende de 200 euros
pour port d'armes.
Un article prévoit
une amende de 15.000 euros
et un an d'emprisonnement.
Vous allez sûrement
me répondre
que les peines sont en hausse.
Elles restent
trop inférieures
à la montée
de la violence
dans notre société.
Le rôle de la justice
est de dissuader,
de punir et de réparer.
Actuellement,
elle ne remplit
aucun des trois critères.
C'est pourquoi
je vous le demande,
que comptez-vous
mettre en place afin
que notre justice
joue son rôle,
pour que plus que jamais
des jeunes n'aient
à porter le cercueil
d'un camarade?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Eric Dupond-Moretti,
garde des Sceaux,
ministre de la Justice.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti:
Madame la députée
Michèle Martinez,
votre indécente démagogie
fait que vous n'avez pas voulu
entendre
les mots du grand-père
du petit Thomas.
Vous préférez
en réalité opposer
la France rurale
et tranquille, catholique
et blanche,
à la France des cités,
à la France des Mohamed,
des Mouloud
et des Rachid.
Nous faisons en sorte
que les trafiquants
de drogue,
que les criminels
qui sont dans les cités
soient interpellés
et jugés
de plus en plus sévèrement.
Je pense aussi
aux Français qui vivent
dans nos quartiers,
dans les cités,
et qui ne méritent pas
de lire
sur les murs: "Mort aux Arabes."
Nos frères juifs ont peur,
nos frères musulmans
ont peur aussi.
Vos propos
sont incendiaires
et ils amènent
dans la rue les militants
de l'ultradroite
qui sont bien
plus proches de vous que de moi.
Pour être crédible,
faites le ménage,
chassez de votre bord
les identitaires,
les racistes,
les antisémites
qui sont en réalité
planqués
dans vos officines
économiques
et qui viennent sévèrement
d'être condamnés
par la cour d'appel de Paris.
Les Français
ne sont pas dupes:
vous ne réussirez pas
votre entreprise malsaine.
Les Français savent
que le général Manoukian
ne s'appelait
ni Bernard, ni Marcel.
Vous êtes le miroir inversé
de l'extrême gauche.
Ils nous font croire
que nous détestons
les musulmans.
Vous qui n'êtes plus là,
vous faites croire
que les Blancs sont menacés.
Personne n'est dupe!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Justine Gruet
pour Les Républicains.
- Justine Gruet:
Je pense que ma question aurait pu
intéresser les députés
du Rassemblement National.
Madame la Première
ministre, des milliers
de nos concitoyens
ont été destinataires
d'un avis de taxe d'habitation
ces derniers jours.
Ils ont reçu un courrier
de l'administration fiscale.
Cela n'a rien d'étonnant.
en ont été destinataires.
Comment en est-on arrivé
à cette situation?
L'administration a décidé
de tout automatiser
en confiant la gestion
des impôts locaux
à la plate-forme Gérer
mes biens immobiliers.
Les contribuables
auraient commis
des erreurs en renseignant
leurs données.
Il ne s'agit pas d'un simple
bug informatique
qui aurait généré
des erreurs à la marge,
mais bien d'un problème
plus profond
et plus grave, révélateur d'une
dérive d'hypercentralisation.
Les Français font face
à de vraies difficultés
dans leur démarche.
L'administration
les entretient
et les amplifie.
Notre pays détient
le triste record
du niveau d'impôts,
de taxes et de cotisations
le plus élevé d'Europe.
Pourtant,
nos services publics
sont de moins en
moins efficients,
de moins en
moins présents
dans nos territoires.
Nos compatriotes n'ont
plus d'interlocuteur
en face d'eux.
Malgré leur bonne
volonté,
ce ne sont pas les agents
des maisons France services
qui seront en capacité
de tout régler.
On voit le résultat
de la renationalisation
de la taxe d'habitation.
Elle a perdu l'efficacité
de nos territoires
qui maîtrisaient
parfaitement le sujet.
Quand allons-nous
en finir
avec cette technocratie
qui se pose
en nouvelle classe
dirigeante, prenant
des décisions déconnectées
de la réalité
de nos concitoyens?
Etes-vous prêts
à redonner à chacun
son rôle?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame
Olivia Grégoire,
ministre en charge des Petites
et Moyennes entreprises,
de l'Artisanat et du Tourisme.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci.
Madame la députée Justine Gruet,
veuillez excuser l'absence
de Bruno Le Maire,
qui est en Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Mais je suis là!
Je vous apporte une réponse.
Bruno Le Maire l'a dit ainsi
la semaine passée:
il ne s'agit pas d'un bug
de la plate-forme Gérer
mes biens immobiliers,
mais bien d'une erreur
dans un processus que l'on peut
qualifier d'industriels.
39 millions de foyers
fiscaux, 24 millions
de propriétaires,
4 millions d'avis
de taxe d'habitation
sur les résidences secondaires
émis chaque année.
Quand je dis
qu'il ne pas d'un bug
de la plate-forme,
c'est qu'on ne peut
pas se défausser
en disant que la machine
n'a pas su gérer.
C'est donc entièrement
notre faute, j'avais
à coeur de le préciser.
Chaque année,
nous avons entre 250
et 400.000 informations
sur la taxe d'habitation
sur les résidences
secondaires liées
à des changements
d'adresse
qui n'ont pas été signalées.
C'est encore la raison
principale
des avis envoyés
à tort cette année.
Il y a des locataires
qui ne nous
ont pas signalé
leur changement d'adresse
sur la déclaration
automatique de revenus.
Cela touche souvent
les plus jeunes,
qui déménagent souvent.
Il convient d'insister
sur la nécessité
de modifier
son adresse, même
sur les déclarations automatiques.
Bruno Le Maire a précisé
que la correction serait
automatique
et qu'il n'y avait rien
à faire, si la réponse intéresse
certains députés.
Bruno Le Maire
a donc rappelé
que la direction générale
des finances publiques
est en train de résoudre
ces erreurs
et qu'elle s'en excuse.
Nous sommes en train
de les corriger.
Merci pour votre question.
Il n'y a rien à faire,
la correction
est automatique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
René Pilato
pour le groupe
La France Insoumise.
- René Pilato:
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre de l'Intérieur.
Monsieur Darmanin,
vos services ont-ils peur
du contrôle citoyen
sur les élections?
Gravée auparavant
dans le code électoral,
l'annexion des listes
de procurations
aux procès-verbaux
de chaque bureau
de vote est supprimée
par le décret
du 11 mars 2021.
Celui du 22
décembre confirme
que ces listes restent en mairie.
La circulaire
du 31 décembre,
à quatre mois
de la présidentielle
et cinq mois
des législatives,
ordonne aux maires
de ne plus annexer
ces listes aux PV.
Cet enchaînement méticuleux rend
techniquement impossible
la vérification
d'un scrutin,
car la préfecture n'est
plus le lieu centralisateur.
En 10 jours, délai
imparti pour faire
un recours,
prendre rendez-vous
dans les 22 mairies
de ma circonscription
est quasiment impossible.
Pour celles composés
de centaines
de communes,
cela relève du miracle,
une capacité
qui est peu commune
chez les candidats.
Le matériel peut
toujours être rapatrié
au Conseil constitutionnel
sur demande
d'un avocat, qu'il s'agit
de payer 3000 euros,
pour y faire ce qui se faisait
gratuitement
en préfecture.
Ensuite, venir consulter
le tout à Paris,
et ce en une demi-journée.
Une gageure.
Monsieur Darmanin,
nous l'avons
fait pour ma circonscription
de Charente.
Sur 134 procurations manuscrites,
64 n'existaient pas.
Le résultat s'est
enjoué à 24 voix,
cela laisse
pour le moins perplexe.
Monsieur le ministre,
des personnes malhonnêtes
en ont profité pour tricher.
Triche en Charente,
erreurs de bulletins
dans les bureaux
de l'Ariège, profession
de foi non distribuée
un peu partout...
Comment comptez-vous
corriger le tir
aux élections européennes de juin?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin,
ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Permettez-moi
de dire
que je n'ai pas
tout à fait compris
votre question.
S'il y a 64 erreurs
de procurations
et que vous avez gagné
à 24 voix,
je me pose la question
de votre présence
dans l'hémicycle.
La question
que vous posez
est celle de l'accès
aux documents électoraux,
qui sont la preuve
que le scrutin s'est passé
dans de bonnes possibilités
et de pouvoir contester.
Vous ne faites pas confiance
aux maires
de votre circonscription,
puisque c'est bien
sur la base de la mairie
que l'on tient
des listes
électorales
et qu'on les garde
pour pouvoir permettre
la possibilité
de vérification
pendant 48 heures.
Je vous recommande
d'avoir confiance
dans les maires
de votre circonscription.
Ils agissent
non pas en tant qu'élu
mais en tant que représentant
de l'Etat.
Vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'être tout seul
pour voir les listes
électorales,
vous pouvez déléguer
des personnes.
Les choses étaient parfois
différentes avant.
On bataillait pour récupérer
ces sujets électoraux
en moins de 48 heures.
Vous pouvez aussi
photographier
ces listes électorales.
Vous avez aussi
tout à fait le droit
de pouvoir en demander
une ampliation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Lionel Vuibert
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Lionel Vuibert: Vous m'entendez?
Merci, Madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Aujourd'hui, je souhaite
rendre hommage
à Alan, ce jeune
Ardennais de 17 ans
qui a fait preuve
d'un courage exceptionnel
lors de l'attaque
au couteau en Irlande,
la semaine passée.
Le 17 novembre
dernier, cet élève
de terminale en stage
dans un restaurant
de Dublin a été témoin d'une
violente attaque
à l'arme blanche.
Aidé d'un livreur
brésilien,
il est parvenu
à désarmer l'agresseur,
se blessant
légèrement aux mains
et au visage.
Au cours de cette attaque,
cet homme
a ainsi poignardé
cinq personnes,
dont trois enfants.
L'un des trois enfants
et une enseignante
ont été grièvement blessés.
Armé de son courage
et au péril
de sa propre sécurité,
l'intervention d'Alan
a probablement permis
d'éviter le pire.
A n'en pas douter, c'est un héros.
Sitôt les événements,
le président
de la République et le ministre
de l'Education nationale
ont appelé le jeune lycéen
pour le remercier
au nom de la patrie.
Député des Ardennes,
il était pour moi
une évidence
de citer le courage
et le sang-froid
exceptionnel dont Alan
a fait preuve, et lui témoigner
la reconnaissance
de la représentation
nationale ici réunie.
Nelson Mandela
disait: "Le courage
n'est pas l'absence
de peur
mais la capacité
de vaincre
ce qui fait peur."
A n'en pas douter,
Alan a vaincu
sa peur pour réaliser cet
acte de bravoure.
A l'instar de Mamoudou Gassama,
ce jeune malien
de 22 ans qui a sauvé un enfant
de 4 ans suspendu
dans le vide en 2018
en escaladant
la façade d'un immeuble
parisien,
ou de ces quatre élèves
d'un lycée
de Perpignan qui ont sauvé
de la noyade
une mère et son jeune
fils, nous pouvons
être fiers de cette jeunesse
courageuse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Votre temps est écoulé.
La parole est à madame
Sabrina Agresti-Roubache,
ministre chargée
de la Citoyenneté
et de la ville.
- Sabrina Agresti-Roubache:
Mesdames
et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le député Lionel Vuibert,
je suis heureuse
de cette question.
Vous m'interrogez
sur l'intervention
de ce jeune lycéen des Ardennes.
Par son courage,
Alan a permis d'arrêter
un homme dangereusement
armé à Dublin
il y a quelques jours.
Le président
de la République
et le ministre
de l'Education nationale
et de la Jeunesse
ont pu lui témoigner
la sincère reconnaissance
de la patrie
pour son courage.
Je vous remercie
de me donner l'occasion
de saluer à mon tour
son action héroïque.
Elle fait l'honneur
de la République.
Face à une situation
critique, Alan
a démontré une détermination
sans égale, agissant
avec calme et altruisme.
Cet acte de bravoure
nous rappelle
notre chance
d'avoir une jeunesse engagée,
qui n'hésite pas à prendre
des risques
au nom des principes
de solidarité.
Je souhaite saluer
cette jeunesse courageuse.
Alan incarne l'engagement
républicain.
C'est à ce titre
que je souhaite
le rencontrer
prochainement au ministère
de l'Intérieur,
avec tous les parlementaires
qui voudront bien
se joindre à nous.
Le ministre de l'Intérieur
a déjà prévu
de le décorer.
Je vous propose autre chose:
un certain nombre
de médailles existent
dans notre pays.
Je souhaite que nous puissions
travailler ensemble,
avec les deux chambres,
à la création d'une distinction
spécifique
pour notre jeunesse,
pour mettre en valeur
les valeurs
de citoyenneté.
J'ai envoyé l'invitation
dans l'hémicycle.
Je vous attends au ministère
de l'Intérieur.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.